Michael Strahan he's been full-time of
GMA now for a few months and I was a
correspondent for about six years and as
much as I loved that gig there is one
thing I definitely don't miss but what
time are you guys getting up in the
morning my alarm set for 3:15 over 30
I'm meditating or half an hour
well I'm meditating oh it called sleep
more time as your your absolute must be
in bed time
why I just closed about 850 55 500 K Ali
told me 8:30 she's in bed with you every
night who is the quickest to get ready
in the morning I think I take four
minutes to get ready okay Beyonce being
on the set you can tell this crew really
gets along what would you say the main
asset that brings the best way he brings
so much and you never know what it is
that he's going to bring to the table
and I love that I love that that's what
life is all about teamwork is the
biggest thing teamwork all prepares you
for all of this and I think from the
background levity in the leadership role
of it and Robin had been a leader which
has allowed me to come here and just be
a part of this team and we're
comfortable and grateful we're not even
panicky but they're telling us
I will get to it that's what my five for
good job we welcome you back to GMA
you